ich hatte ihn angekündigt meine Damen
und Herren dass wir Moskau im Blick
behalten dort hast du jetzt vorliegend
Sagella worauf der russische
Außenminister wir wollen hören dass er
zu sagen hat
Passau
herzlichen Dank
folgende Frage
im Zusammenhang mit der letzten
eigennissen in erster Linie zu Boden ne
die Situation entwickelt sich permanent
und der beispiellose sanktionsdrucker
auf Russland hat sich irgendwie die
Haltung Russlands geändert könnten sie
das Formulieren und was meinen sie
wird die Welt oder hört die Welt
Russland zu und wie
schätzen Sie die fortgeführten
Verhandlungen in Belarus ein was ist von
der nächsten Runde zu erwartenden
und das ist eine sehr komplexe Frage die
sie im gestellt haben aber in aller
Kürze sie haben ja viele Themen
angesprochen ich bin davon überzeugt
dass die Welt Russland zuhört aber wie
weit man uns hören kann ich nicht die
Mehrheit versteht worum es geht ist aber
gezwungen
sich einem grausamen Diktat
runterzuordnen offen gesagt ist es
schlimm wenn Menschen sterben Soldaten
und vor allem
Zivilisten Kinder Frauen wie gesagt
Jahre lang im
don-busterfall war und jetzt während der
militärischen spezialoperation die alle
Kriege beenden soll die auf dem Gebiet
der Ukraine
stattfinden könnten
aber
eine Lösung wird gefunden werden
zweifelsfrei die Minimalbedingungen für
uns sind gut bekannt für sie werden auch
in den Verhandlungen mit ukrainischen
Seite
diskutiert wie das in gummail der Fall
war und heute aber die ukrainische
Mannschaft hat wieder Gründe gefunden um
diese Verhandlungen zu vertagen aber
komm vermutlich Anweisungen aus
Washington weil dieses Land überhaupt
nicht eigenständig ist aber die
Verhandlung müssen stattfinden oder
sollen stattfinden
und ich werde jetzt nicht detailliert zu
den Punkten sagen wie verhandelt werden
sollen die sind bekannt und wir können
nicht zulassen dass von der Ukraine eine
direkte angriffsgefahr gegen Russland
ausgeht und die sind und das ist in den
Docs drinne ein Dokumenten des Regimes
sind Kiel fixiert und das dringende
Ukraine nach NATO und in der
vollständige Unwillen der NATO
können sich so zu verhalten hat dass
keine Sicherheit auf die Kosten andere
geschaffen werden soll das sind so die
Hauptgründe aber noch etwas anderes im
Grunde genommen
die Situation in der Ukraine um die
Visierung die rentnerzifizierung dieses
Landes des verhindern dessen sind das dr
Erscheinung des Völkermords fortgeführt
werden und das soll ja Gewalt
eingestellt werden und die Ukraine
sollen die Möglichkeit erhalten über
Schicksal selbst zu bestimmen es geht um
die Weltordnung und nicht zufällig und
er versucht der Westen mit allen
möglichen Mitteln und nicht auf unsere
klaren
eine Vorschläge zu reagieren die sich
auf entsprechende Übereinkünfte Stützen
was die Sicherheitsarchitektur an
betrifft ich habe ja noch mal den
Grundsatz genannt als sowas das
anbetrifft die hohe ze-nator Russland
die ja natürlich jedes Land kann seine
Bündnispartner wählen aber kein Land
kann seine Sicherheit auf die Kosten
eine andere Länder aufbauen und keine
Organisation hat nicht das Recht deine
dominierende R zu beanspruchen und zwar
im Euro einplanen atlantischen Raum was
die NATO jetzt aktiv vorantreibtem und
es geht ja um eine Erhöhung des
Sicherheit des Westens auf Kosten der
Sicherheit russlandsmann sagt uns ihr
seid nicht besorgt wenn die Ukraine oder
ein anderes Land in die NATO aufgenommen
werden sollte das wird keine Gefahr für
die russische Sicherheit
bewirken aber auf welcher Grundlage sagt
uns der Westen was nun unsere Sicherheit
einen betrifft und die Amerikaner haben
ja auch für Europa und Deutschland
bestimmt Energiesicherheit des
europäischen Kontinents und am
beschlossen Nordstrom zwei wird nicht
gebraucht stimmen weil die diese
Sicherheit die Energiesicherheit durch
die amerikanische rng-lieferungen wird
darum geht es es geht darum
man hört uns zusammen hört uns nicht und
man versucht uns für die eigene sich zu
binden wie es in Europa weitergehen soll
und wissen Sie also
ich komme nicht um den Vergleich um hin
Napoleon und Hitler wollten Europa und
der werfen und das haben jetzt die
Amerikaner gemacht
oder stellt sich die Frage gar nicht und
der EU hat man gezeigt wo sie hingehört
und die Sache mit noch Strom zwei hat
gezeigt
wo der Platz Europa ist in der Welt
Arena ist man hat sie gezwungen und das
war's
mir das nächste Mal und wenn er jetzt
gesprochen wird und wenn der westliche
Hauptstädte ihre Forderung
artikulieren hier wird ein Bild
geschaffen auf der Welt Arena den
Hollywood es gibt das absolut der böse
und das absolut gut und das absolut gute
verkörpert sich natürlich in einer
Person die auch der
Drehbuchschreiber dieses Rivers ist es
ist traurig ich bin davon überzeugt dass
diese Hysterie sich legen wird dass
unsere westlichen Partner wieder mal zur
Ruhe kommen und ich stand immer Dialog
bereit bei einer Bedingungen nur auf
Augenhöhe gleichberechtigt mit Respekt
gegenüber den Interessen des anderen um
meine lieben Kollegen ich möchte noch
sagen wir haben
live in
auch alles im Internet jetzt ein
amerikanischer Journalist von NBC
girosinus
herzlichen Dank
Ministerpräsident Putin die wird am
besten häufig
nein isoliert der Politiker beschrieben
der jetzt sehr emotional reagiert wann
haben Sie mit ihm gesprochen nimmt er
noch Ratschläge an
und was und wie also den Putin machst
sie wurde in das anhand dessen was die
restpropaganda sagt dann schreibt der
die letzten Wochen
Präsident Putin unsere
Opposition
detailliert dargelegt und das ist die
Ansicht der russischen Regierung und die
werden in Übereinstimmung mit den
verfassungsmäßigen Befugnissen des
Präsidenten entwickelt und das
Außenministerium der
das Verteidigungsministerium die
Geheimdienste sind daran sind daran
involviert und das ist ganz normale
alltägliche Arbeit und ein mindestens
wöchentlich
finde deine Sitzung der ständigen
Mitglieder des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates statt so werden
Entscheidungen vorbereitet und getroffen
und wir haben in New York genau
so warten sie bitte warten warten sie
bitte
wir haben zwei Fragen ich bitte um
Entschuldigung
bitte sprechen Sie danke
danke
Russland und Amerika
Stabilität gewährleiste du ungeachtet
der Angst vor Kernwaffen Potentialen
können Sie uns versprechen das Russland
nichts kann was meinsetzen wird als
erstes wir haben eine Militär Doktrin
wo die Parameter und die Bedingungen für
den Einsatz von Kernwaffen fixiert sind
und wir haben Winter keine
Sanierung für eine deeskalierung
festgehalten aber und
ich bitte Sie schauen Sie sich die
Äußerungen sehr aufmerksam an in die
erkl Ende und die Person die diese
Verlautbarungen geleistet haben Herr
gestalten will Stolzenberg nur wollte
den radikalsten Kräften im Westen zu
gefallen hatte gesagt niemand kann der
NATO verbieten was die Nase tun will z.B
auch Kernwaffen in Osteuropa zu
stationieren die NATO kann nicht
entscheiden wo sie Kernwaffen
stationiert weil die NATO keine hat die
Amerikaner haben welche aber was als
doldenberg sagen wollte es liegt auf der
Hand und her selenski hat dann
angefangen zu erklären dass wir auf
den auf den Status eines nicht gern
waffenstahls verzichten und uns
Kernwaffen beschaffen wurde mein Kollege
aus Frankreich gesagt hat
wir wissen ja
nationale Symbol der Franzosen ist der
Hahn und der wird sich jetzt so auf und
er hatte neulich auch wieder gesagt
dass Putin wissen soll dass Frankreich
auch gerne Waffen hat
die vor kurzem Leiterin des Foren Office
geworden ist hat gesagt sie ist bereit
auf einen Konflikt zwischen NATO und
Russland und schauen sie bitte noch was
ihr Präsident gesagt hat Herr Weiden
er beantwortete die Frage ob es eine
Alternative gegeben hätte für diese
Sanktionen nein die eine eine
Alternative wäre nur der dritte
Weltkrieg und wir wissen ein dritter
Weltkrieg sein kann waffenkrieg aber das
sind die Köpfe der westlichen Politiker
wo immer dieser kernkrieg drin ist und
nicht in den Köpf und ich versichere sie
eine versichere Ihnen wir werden nicht
zulassen dass irgendwelche Provokationen
uns zwingen dass die Contenance zu
verlieren
aber nur wenn man kriegt entfesseln wird
wenn das sollten diejenigen Bedenken die
solche Pläne hegen
wir gehen jetzt nach New York ABC George
bitte sehr
sehr geehrter Herr Minister
Russland die Ukraine Bomben des Menschen
sterben und
die Welt verurteilt diese Attacken
das ist eine kurze Frage
[Musik]
gebracht haben ich kann
irgendwelche Erfindung nicht
kommentieren es gibt jetzt ein Haufen
Sachen die aus den Fingern gesaugt
werden und den Europa die USA aber
hauptsächlich Europa versucht
Massenmedien zu schließen also
Informationskanäle aus Russland und die
darüber berichten über sein der Ukraine
passiert wie diesem ätherische
spezialoperation sich entwickelt und
Video ukrainischer Armee und vor allem
die ukrainische Neonazi Bataillone
gegenüber der Zivilbevölkerung verhalten
die plündern einfach Ortschaften wenn
sie sich zurückziehen aus dem Don was
z.B
weil die Landwehr Internet
ein anderes technisches Gerät benehmen
sich wie Marodeure und Räuber
und es gibt viele Informationen darüber
welche Provokation nur vorbereitet
werden auch in Mario Paul und auf
anderen Gebieten wo die Ukraine jetzt
versuchen Burger als lebende
Schutzschilder zu benutzen sprechen Sie
mal mit den Hintern mit den Arabern mit
den Afrikanern die jetzt versuchen die
Ukraine zu verlassen die lässt man nicht
außer Landes und buchstäblich gestern
hat er ja indische premier mit dem
russischen Präsidenten in besprochen und
hat seine Besorgnis zum Ausdruck
gebracht weil ein indische Student den
chariv ums Leben gekommen ist da gibt's
keine russischen aber wir sehen eine
Situation wo auf dem Bahnhof
Ausländer nicht weggelassen werden und
die auch über Russland z.B das Land
verlassen wollen aber wir sind bereit
diese Studenten aufzunehmen ich habe
jetzt einfach keine Zeit die Fakten
aufzuzählen besuchen Sie die Webseite
unseres Ministeriums wo detailliert
dargelegt ist und was jetzt
Regime macht sie mögen das Wort Killer
und auf der Seite des KiWa Regimes
kämpfen echte Killer
Peking wenn der Leitung Media
Corporation of China
meine
dispräsident selenski der erste jüdische
Präsident eine
Neonazis es ist schwer zu erklären wie
ihre Präsident selenski
kann in einer Gesellschaft wo die
Neonazis und der Nähe und Narzissmus
üppige Blüten schlagen und die
marschieren marschieren aufmachen ihre
fackelzüge und für diese fackelzüge hat
Präsident zu Lenski
seinem
Ehrenwache mit zur Verfügung gestellt
die für die führende Übungen durch die
werden ausgebildet
um eine starken Kampf zu üben ja die
Versionen Provokation
erklärt dass sein Großvater gekämpft hat
dann schauen Sie mal welche Gesetze
herunterzeichnet wie kann ein Präsident
der ein Mann des Friedens sein müsste
wie jeder Jude ein Gesetz über die
indigenen Völker in der Ukraine
unterzeichnen und dann gehören die
Russen nicht mit dazu wie kann eine
Präsident der kein Rassist ist
ein Gesetzes unterstützen und zu
unterzeichnen die russische Sprache
nicht nur in den Schulen verbieten was
schon genug ja das sondern überhaupt im
alltäglichen Leben
es ist dort verboten also du kommst in
die Apotheke und willst eine Arznei dann
darfst du das nicht russisch machen und
in Russland in der Krim
manchen Westen hat dann ja darum da
gibt's drei Amtssprachen russisch die
krimptatarische Sprache und die Ukraine
schon jede russische Bürger der in der
Krim lebt hat das Recht
in überall bei Behörden und sowas die
eigene Sprache zu verwenden und es muss
die Antwort in seiner Sprache bekommen
ich könnte noch vieles aufzählen aber
schauen Sie mal sie mögen es so schrille
Bilder
und sie haben auch keine Zeit um sich
den Fakten auseinanderzusetzen sich
einzulesen
Dienst auf die Webseite unseres
Ministeriums oder des
Verteidigungsministeriums der Russischen
Föderation aber ich weiß denn man wird
ihnen nicht erlauben dazu was zu sagen
eine französische Journalistin glaube
ich Präsident macron hatte gesagt
eine Lüge aber er hat die Antwort
bekommen und am besten hat das eine
Landsfrau von ihm gemacht eine
französische Journalisten die im Don
Bass gewesen ist und gesehen beschrieben
hat wie Schulen beschossen werden wie
zwei Frauen die in der Frage die in der
Schule gearbeitet haben erschossen
worden und wie sieht das den besten
gezeigt hat und der Westen will das
nicht sehen und sie durfte das nicht
veröffentlichen aber in den sozialen
Medien ist diese Komment
zugänglich sie sollten sich mit den
Fakten auseinandersetzen und nicht so
tun dass dieser Hollywood of river
sich entwickelt wird das ihre Kollegen
geschrieben haben auf der Grundlage hier
haben wir das absolut Böse da das
absolut gut dann
Media Corporation of China
auch noch anderen
Journalisten die Gelegenheit ergeben
Fragen neben Fragen zu stellen bitte
zeigen Sie ein bisschen Respekt vor
ihren Kollegen
also Media Corporation Frau Lied und Tom
aus Peking
herzlichen Dank
Media Corporation of China und wir haben
vor kurzem einige Amt Personen aus
Europa interviewt und die haben erklärt
dass die NATO für sich in
keine Osterweiterung wollte und das so
Russland keine Probleme haben dürfte
aber
gegenwärtig klingen solche erläutere
solche Erklärung früher ja jetzt nicht
woher kommt diese Veränderung
und
wissen ja das Sputnik und RT in Europa
geblockt worden und in verschiedenen
Medien sehen wir diese Informationen man
kann Tatsachen nicht verbergen dieser
Klärung die diese eingangs erwähnt haben
die in meiner gegenüber der sowjetischen
Führung dann der russischen geäußert hat
das ist keine Osterweiterung geben wird
das soll keine Infrastruktur Objekte
militärische Art der NATO
in östlich von der U-Bahn passiert
werden und dann
kam es so fünf
erweiterungswellen mit der Allianz und
jedes Mal wurde die Rhetorik dieser
Allianz und die militärischen Planung
die militärischen Übung zielten immer
mehr gegen Russland ab wir haben das
häufig thematisiert die Aufmerksamkeit
darauf gel
aber wir
treffen uns keine Reaktion die bestätigt
hätte dass die NATO
gleichberechtigt und respektvoll
gegenüber unseren Sorgen mit uns bereit
gewesen wäre zu sprechen und dann die
Uhr
und in Istanbul 99 und 2010 und hast
danach und die Erklärung
in 20
2 beim Gipfel wo gesagt wurde dass
niemand seine Sicherheit auf Kosten der
Sicherheit andere aufbauen würde und das
keine Organisation im oze Raum im
eurotländischen Raum
die Dominanz für sich beanspruchen kann
in diesem Raum und die NATO oder macht
das eben nicht die hält sich nicht daran
sie haben eine gute Frage gestellt warum
passiert das und warum
muss diese Position
behalten werden das ist wirklich der
starsinnige Wunsch
Überlegenheit zu erhalten und zwar in
jedem Bereich und allen zu zeigen dass
die NATO die Ordnung in Europa bestimmte
und sollten work hat er noch erklärt
dass die NATO die globale Verantwortung
für die globale Sicherheit trägt
und dass das eine verteidigungsallianz
ist
das ist einfach nur Gerede wenn es um
eine verteidigungsallianz gehen würde
wenn Sie eine solche wäre genau dann
müsste sie sich verteidigen sie ist aber
nicht angegriffen worden aber der
Lernzeit entschieden wir verteidigen uns
jetzt am entlang der Berliner Mauer
jetzt ist er weg wo können wir uns jetzt
verteidigen und man begann sich Richtung
Osten zu erweitern und
immer einseitig oder diese sogenannte
Verteidigungslinie gezogen und die
befindet sich jetzt
in der Russischen Föderation Präsident
Putin hat das x-mal gesagt und seinen
öffentlichen Auftritten in den
Gesprächen lang Gesprächen mit
westlichen Spitzenpolitikern und der hat
das immer dargelegt klar und deutlich
und wenn gesprochen wird bilateral z.B
ja da wird Verständnis gezeigt aber es
kam wenn Sie alle zusammenkommen dann
passiert was mit denen ja die USA geben
den Ton an und schreiben ihre Befehle
Anweisung das ist sehr traurig nur weil
wir sind nach wie vor dialogbereit aber
unter dieser Dialog wird irgendwann
einmal beginnen aber das die NATO
versucht hat mit der Ukraine zu tun das
wissen wir wir wissen wie der Staat zu
Streich stattgefunden hat ein
Staatsstreich der durch nichts
provoziert gewesen ist weil
das passiert immer Tag nach der
Unterzeichnung
nee das Abkommens zwischen dem
Präsidenten und dem und der Opposition
über die Durchführung einer Wahl wo die
Opposition gesiegt hat und warum nicht
so Schatz Streich oder Umsturz man hätte
diese Übereinkunft erfüllen können und
niemand wäre auf die Idee gekommen auf
der Krim ein Aufstand gegen die
Putschisten
auszurufen weil das ist doch alles
bekannt es liegt auf der Hand aber in
der gegenwärtigen Situation ich sage es
nochmal
hat aus der Ukraine schon lange eine Art
Anti Russland gemacht einen Brückenkopf
um alles russische zu bekämpfen das war
ein Teil des großen geopolitischen
Spiels ist bignifische Ansicht in
Russland plus Ukraine ist eine
Supermärkte Ukraine ohne Russland ist
überhaupt nichts und
ich glaube er hat auch noch gesagt dass
man die Ukraine nutzen sollte auf jeder
Art und Weise um russisch Interessen ein
flusskultur zu unterminieren und es
wurde auch dazu aufgerufen die Ukraine
zu nutzen um die orthodoxe Kirche
zu zerstören poroschenko hat damit
angefangen und Präsident selenski setzt
das Aktiv fort und darum ich sage es
noch mal wir haben genügend guten Willen
aber unsere Interessen
und werden höchst ständig beeinträchtigt
und man schafft auch physische
Bedrohungen für die russische Sicherheit
und das werden wir nicht zulassen wir
dürfen das nicht zulassen wir gehen nach
Europa
entschuldigung ich hätte noch eine Frage
eine ganz kurze
wie schätzen Sie die laufende Situation
nach den Verhandlungen mit der Ukraine
und welche Probleme nach den
Verhandlungen
angefangen möchte jetzt der Fall sein
und hinterleiter der Delegation der die
Verhandlung führte mit der Ukraine wird
nach Abschluss auch eine Erklärung
gegeben und dann werden wir alles
erfahren
Paris in der Leitung
ja jetzt Mister
Frank Perlmann
24 Russland ist jetzt international
isoliert
und nur vier Ländern haben gegen die
Resolution gestimmt und Russland wird ja
aufgerufen alle Kampfhandlungen
einzustellen die wir unvollversammlung
gefordert das und im das ist doch ein
Fiasko eine Niederlage Russlands sind
politischen Sinn was die Handlung meines
Landes an betrifft unseres Landes an
betrifft wir sind überzeugt dass wir
richtig handeln ich sage es noch mal es
ist sehr sehr schlecht dass Menschen
sterben
aber
diplomatisches chiasko was das
diplomatische Talent und Geschick das
weiß nicht sein betrifft ungefähr
14.000 Menschen sind während der
Kriegsjahre im Don Bass gestorben weder
ihr Kanal um noch andere westliche
Medien
haben nicht mal daran gedacht den Don
was aufzusuchen mal zu schauen wie die
Menschen dort leben die das ukrainische
Regime für Terroristen erklärt hat die
haben niemanden angegriffen die sind
angegriffen worden man hat sie als
Terroristen gebrannt Markt und schauen
Sie mal wie diese Menschen tagtäglich
beschossen werden wie Zivilisten
erschossen werden wie man Schulen und
Kindergärten zerstört wie terroristische
Anschläge durchgeführt werden
was jetzt die Kriterien ihres Berufes
einen betrifft wenn Sie
das werden wenn der Westen ist gesagt
hat dann ist das so und wenn
sie acht Jahre
Medien sondern auch Politikern acht
Jahre Torpedierung der Minsk Abkommen da
ist das ukrainische Regime hat sie nicht
noch nicht erfüllt sondern nach wie vor
Gewalt gegen Zivilisten angemeldet
angewendet und diese acht Jahre Ignoranz
und schweigen wenn das dein
diplomatischer Triumph sein soll wenn
Sie das meint okay sie vertreten ja
freie Medien wenn ich das richtig sehe
aber wenn Sie die Ansicht sind dass wenn
Russland seine Interessen verteidigt und
ähm in der gennato ist einig wie nie die
Nato hat ja nach Methoden gesucht es
sich wieder einen Sinn zu geben weil
nach dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion und das
war schon gepackt zwar in dieser Sinn
weg dann kam Afghanistan und siegreich
hat sich die NATO dort zurückgezogen und
hat er wieder keinen Grund und einig zu
an einem Seil zu ziehen und macron hat
ja gesagt niemand und er wird jemanden
erlauben strategische Autonomie zu haben
die USA haben das bei euch das ist
vermutlich der diplomatische Triumph der
USA und dann werde ich mal lieber nicht
kommentieren
wäre das diplomatische in Europa zu
verantworten haben wird und was
sie erwähnt haben wir wissen sehr sehr
gut mit welchen Methoden
die werden unsere westlichen Kollegen
solche Ergebnisse erzielen das ist reine
Erpressung
brechen und allen Ländern ohne Ausnahme
wird sagt werden abgestimmt wird dann
werdet ihr so abstimmen wie wir es euch
sagen und man erinnerte Politik könnte
westlichen Ländern daran wer wo seine
Konten hat wo wir wissen Kinder
studieren ist so laufen die denke ich
weil wir viele meiner Freunde
mir mal
erzählende wie sie unter Druck gesetzt
werden und sie sagen wir können nicht
anders abstimmen hier geht es um mein
Leben und meine Familie und mir
Wohlergehen ja mit solchen Methoden
werden
diplomatische Triumph erzählt herzlichen
Glückwunsch dazu aber die Wahrheit wird
schon ihren Weg finden und ich lande sie
noch mal niemand von ihm scheint jemals
bei uns auf unsere Website gewesen zu
sein wo wir wirklich Beweise haben dafür
was die ukrainische Militärmaschine die
Neonazis im Don Bass angerichtet haben
und darum wir fühlen uns politisch nicht
einsam
herzlichen Dank
noch eine Frage wenn Sie gestatten
zu
zur Veränderung der Situation in der
Ukraine
zu entscheiden oder ein Video Ukraine
weiterleben will und wer dieses Land
führen soll weil das ist Sache des
ukrainischen Volkes nein aller Völker
die in der multinationalen Ukraine Leben
herzlichen nee danke
in Großbritannien
sind sie da
folgende Frage
ein Mädchen das sie in einer Schule
getötet wurde durch die Russen im Kiew
ich weiß Sie haben eine Tochter schauen
Sie mir bitte in die Augen und sagen Sie
mir wie können sie nachts schlafen wenn
sie wissen dass russische Bomben und
Kugeln Kinder töten
jedes Menschenleben
ist unendlich viel wert aber
Kampfhandlungen für und so Opfern nicht
nur unter Soldaten sondern auch unter
Zivilisten unsere Soldaten die an der
spezialoperation beteiligt sind haben
einen stricken Befehl nur
Präzisionswaffen einzusetzen gegen
militärische Infrastruktur und auch
etwas
und wo ukrainische Soldaten stationiert
sind werden nicht irgendwelchen Schlägen
ausgesetzt und ich kann nur noch mal
mein Beileid all denen gegenüber zum
Ausdruck zu bringen
Präzisionswaffen aber nur hunderte
friedliche Zivilisten sind bereits tot
und der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof bereitet Ermittlungen
vor und wir werden sie sich dort
verteidigen
da werden schon Leute zusehen und so und
sie werden ja die Leute emotional
Aufladen das ist ja Job soweit ich das
sehe weil wir sind kein weniger ein
Medium sondern mehr ein Instrument um
Menschen etwas einzuprügeln was die
westlichen Politik brauchen und wollen
ich sage es Ihnen noch mal
ich rechtfertige keinerlei Handlungen
die zum Tod von Zivilisten führen aber
nicht wir haben den Begriff kalatarell
damage erfunden
während ihre Abenteuer im Iraker vorher
in anderen Ländern auch in Lateinamerika
in Libyen
da haben Sie schon mal so emotional
aufgeladen die Situation
im Irak und in Libyen beleuchtet wo es
Hunderttausende zivile Opfer gehabt ich
kann mich nicht dran erinnern ihre Frage
ist rhetorisch
ja ja lavrove das habe ich gemacht aber
sie haben diesen Krieger begonnen und
das Blut polinas klebt dann ihren Händen
diese Spielchen zu spielen ist sie
ich habe meine Haltung meiner Position
auch was die humanitären Aspekte die
Operation an betrifft dargelegt aber ich
möchte dass Sie und ich beweise sie
werden das so machen wie sie es wollen
aber ich möchte ganz einfach
jeder Journalist die du Journalisten
muss doch ein Gewissen haben auch wenn
sie für geldarbeiten wie haben sie sich
die 8 Jahre lang Verhalten als solche
Mädchen Frauen
Greise zu Tausenden getötet worden im
Don Bass durch das Kira Regime kommen
Sie auf unsere Seite
Website des Ministerium
möchte jetzt ihnen nicht die Zeit weiter
stehlen wenn
die Tiere folgen an betrifft ja und wenn
Sie sich dafür interessieren dann gehen
Sie auf die Websites die sie bisher
sozusagen beruflich nicht ins Auge
gefasst haben
nur jetzt zum red Morris von sociated
press
drastisch guten Tag Herr Minister einen
schönen guten Tag russland hatte
offiziell 500 Soldaten innerhalb einer
Woche der
Operationen verloren es gibt andere
Zahlen
und es ist eine
teure Kampagne teurer als
Afghanistan oder Tschetschenien
offizielle Wörter war so dass man die
Russen mit offenen Armen empfangen würde
und
eine subjektive Ansicht es gibt Verluste
sind solche Situationen geht's nicht
ohne Verluste das habe ich schon gesagt
aber
nun hat das alles nicht nach Plan läuft
ich glaube nicht dass sie die Pläne
kennen und die vertraulich sind und die
Grundlage der Handlung unserer
Gruppierung bilden die auf Befehl des
Präsidenten eine militärische
spezialoperation
noch mal man kann diese Situation nicht
losgelöst von allem anderen betrachten
losgelöst von den letzten 30 Jahren da
gab es ja viele Ereignisse im Verhältnis
zwischen dem Russland und den besten und
dem Rest der Welt und USA Putin hat
mehrfach gesagt die in Gefahr ist an
unsere Grenzen gerückt
[Musik]
das Pentagon besorgt ist durch das
Schicksal der Objekte
[Musik]
in der Ukraine weil das Pentagon und
zwei biologische Militär Labors
aufgebaut hat den Kiefer unter ein Tier
von der norddessa und jetzt haben diese
sorgen dass die Kontrolle verloren geht
und wissen Sie was das ist und die
Amerikanern
sich ein michionismus Überprüfung im
Rahmen der Konvention über das Verbot
von b-waffen aufzubauen und bei uns
solche Objekte an der russischen Grenze
auf und weil mein Mann hatte Stütz so
zerrichten die Briten z.B es gab viele
viele Sachen
im Spiel und man hat die ukrainische
Armee ausgebildet und klar nicht um
gegen Polen zu kämpfen und wenn im Irak
Sachen passiert sind als die USA erklärt
haben dass es eine Gefahr für die
nationale Sicherheit der USA haben sie
sich mal gefragt 10000 km
wieso wollen die USA dort Ordnung
schaffen nein der Gedanke ist ihnen
nicht gekommen weil das ist eine
hochmütige großmachtshaltung aber wenn
Russland sagt wir fühlen uns bedroht nö
es gibt keine Gefahr ihr seid dann
Sicherheit nein wir bestimmen die
Bedingungen die erforderlich sind für
uns für unsere Sicherheit an unseren
Grenzen
wir müssen uns nicht irgendwo
10000 km Entfernung ein und versuchen
dort unsere Regeln durchzusetzen das war
eine entwurm erzwungene Entscheidung
weil man uns nicht zugehört hat und uns
die letzten 30 Jahre lang belogen hat
und irgendwann werden wir wieder
miteinander sprechen müssen aber auf der
Grundlage dessen dass alle sich dann
auch daran halten wenn es darum geht ihr
eigenes Sicherheit nicht auf Kosten
anderer aufzubauen und keine Dominanz
nur in gleichberechtigter Dialog aber
dazu sind die westlichen Kollegen nicht
bereit und
stellen sich jetzt als das absolute gute
Darm es geht ja auch wirklich um den
Mist auch alle diplomatischen Methoden
und man zwingt klein und mittlere
Staaten so zu handeln wie es ihnen
befohlen wird und und in der
Weltgeschichte passiert das nicht mal
auch in der russischen
und darum würde ich keine voreiligen
Schlüssel ziehen es geht um eine
Operation die hat klare Ziele
Demilitarisierung im Sinne das dort drin
keine Waffen sind die Russland bedrohen
könnten die Entnazifizierung weil das
Urteil von die Urteile von Nürnberg hat
niemand bislang aufgehoben und es geht
um Garantien für die Ukraine ohne NATO
Mitgliedschaft der Präsident hat
unterstrichen die naturerweiterung ist
nicht akzeptabel aber wir sind bereit
darüber zu sprechen wie man die
Sicherheit Europas die Ukraine und der
Russischen Föderation gewährleisten kann
so wir gehen wieder nach Paris TF1
am Wochenende
russland will dass die Ukraine
kapituliert
mit dem Präsidenten selensky zu tun zu
haben und was soll er tun um die
Kampfhandlungen
zum Stopp zu bringen oder möchten Sie
das Ganze Staatsgebiet des Landes
übernehmen und die ukrainische Armee
vollkommen zu vernichten ich möchte noch
mal darauf erinnern also nochmal
überhaupt nicht zugehört also wir sind
zu den Verhandlungen bereit und halt
sehr Präsident sehr Lenski
um die Verhandlungen
hat Präsident
zugesagt dann hat
selenski mal wieder abgesagt und dann
doch
kam die Delegation an
obwohl wenn auch einen Tag später
haben unsere Verhandlungsposition auf
dem Tisch
und wir sind durchaus bereit mit denen
zu sprechen aber wir können uns das
nicht leisten auf der Ukraine
für unsere Sicherheit zu behalten und
die demilitäre sie demelitisierung also
die Vernichtung der betreuenden Waffen
das
unbedingt erfolgen und
friedensamen Abkommen sollte diesen
Punkten halten
Fernsehsender TF1
[Musik]
sprechen oft miteinander hat Frankreich
eine besondere Rolle in diesem
konfliktiere
also Frankreich ist ein bisschen was von
kostenerfahrungen von beiden
friedensvermittlungen
Präsident
bei den Kriegshandlungen in der Georgien
damals auch behandelt und Präsident
macron und seine Vorfahren haben damals
geleistet
und auch bei der Ausbau Ausarbeitung des
Minsk
Abkommen Frankreich
ein wichtiges geleistet dabei aber nach
der Unterzeichnung von Münster Abkommen
und nachdem Sicherheitsgrad das
abgestempelt hat weder Frankreich noch
Deutschland haben etwas gedacht um die
Ukraine dazu zu zwingen die Bestimmungen
des Abkommens zu umzusetzen
noch mehr die beiden Staaten haben die
Notwendigkeit der direkten Verhandlungen
zwischen
Kia und abtrünnigen Republiken
aufzunehmen und sie haben immer
behauptet der richtige Schuld in
Russland sei
schuld an dieser Sackgasse da haben wir
immer auf die
Resolution der Sicherheitsrates der UNO
hingewiesen
wo es
schwarzer Fall steht die Verhandlungen
zwischen Kia und Separatisten sollten
aufgenommen werden ja ich weiß Präsident
Marion greift oft die Initiative auch
vor
kurzem hat Präsident
macron mit Präsident Putin gesprochen
und gerade zu diesem Zeitpunkt oder viel
ich weiß telefonieren die beiden
miteinander
und wir wollen hoffen dass diese
Vermittlung dieser Kontakte doch mal
also zum Erfolg beitragen aber auf der
vorhandenen
Bestimmungen die im internationalen
rechten gelten als Präsident macronen
heute
gesagt hat
in der Ukraine das ist eine Lüge
da nie wieder bin ich sehr verwundert
und mir
das kann ich nicht begreifen
in der Ukraine gegenüber Russen also
aggressive Aussage
[Musik]
herr Scholz und das kannst du da
Deutschlands der Partner oder
Frankreichs im
[Musik]
normandieformatik
in der Ukraine sind die Erben der Nazis
das ist ganz anderes angenehm von einem
deutschen sowas zu hören
mögen das lieber nicht einsehen
herr Scholz hat gesagt Lager in Europa
ist sehr ernsthaft und die haben wir
seit 75 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen da
wundere ich mich als die Nato hat die
serbischen Staaten bombardiert
die Situation nicht so angespannt also
immer haben wir mit den doppelten
Standards zu tun und auch heutzutage
Amerikaner
immer solche Bedingungen solche
Vorbedingungen schaffen möchte wollen
dass die westliche Partner denn der die
westlichen Partner sich alles leisten
können und vor allem die Vereinigten
Staaten ja ich verstehe sie sind dort
die Solidarität ja Verbündeten verbunden
ja aber die ganze Welt hat das nicht
leichter
nur schönes aber noch mal muss ich sagen
die
vermittlungsanstrengend von Herrn macron
wir begrüßen und der Präsident Putin hat
Präsident Mark wohl mehrmals erklärt
welche Auswege sehen wir aus der
heutigen Lage und wenn hermagoran
Präsident
selenski überreden kann dann können wir
von Erfolg sprechen
zweite Frage bitte
Jever PSK USA Probleme
betrachten sie als eine Akte des Krieges
sehen Sie dabei die Voraussetzung für
den Atomkrieg
sind eigentlich von westlichen Ländern
initiiert alle haben davon gesprochen
die Atomwaffen müssen näher an Russland
stationiert werden selensky und
Franzosen und andere
Mitglieder
also all diese Reden
versuchen sie eigentlich dazu uns zu
beschuldigen ich möchte noch mal
bezahlen unterzeichnen
angesprochen sondern von ihnen und
dadurch wollen sie das Publikum
in der Stimmung zu halten
ihren Aussagen von Russen geht die
Gefahr aus
und alle sollten Sie von Russen bedroht
fühlen
[Musik]
um eine
unfairer Konkurrenz und das betrifft
praktisch alle Gebiete der menschlichen
Tätigkeiten Sport Kunst also das ist
einfach nicht fair und deshalb hege ich
noch die Hoffnung dass unsere
Hauptpartner
doch dieser die Anlage noch mal prüfen
und dann können wir auf der
gleichberechtigten Grundlage auf der
Augenhöhe und weiterverhandeln all diese
Gespräche die die Welt von heute wird
anders sein und die
Russland wie erziehe ich dem die dem
internationalen Diktat fügen sollen nur
Lehrer Worte
ich danke ihnen
Garagen
Ergebnisse in der
unvollversammlung gewinnt erwähnt sie
kennen die Ergebnisse sie wissen auch
wieder eine Sicherheitsrat abgestimmt
hat und bei diesem Verhältnis gegenüber
den russischen Position
werden sich die russischen aus dem
politischen Prioritäten ändern die
entwicklungsvektoren
werden wir unsere Richtungen ändern und
noch eine weitere Frage
wenn wir bislang hat es keine
Sicherheitsgarantien vom Besten gegeben
von ihnen haben wir häufig gehört wie
wichtig das ist und
das wird bestimmt
wird das dazu führen dass
Sicherheitsgarantien vom Westen für
Russland gewährt werden dann fliegt er
sagt alle Konflikte Enden mit
Übereinkünften und das hängt aber nicht
von uns ab unsere Position ist bekannt
aber man hat uns 30 Jahre lang nicht
zugehören man hat unsere Sorgen nicht
ernst genommen sie sind im Westen
bekannt die wurden hochnäsige
ignor aber das geht nicht bis in die
Unendlichkeit das sind Ewigkeit das
können nur Naivlingen hoffen und ob wir
unsere Richtung wechseln wir sind bereit
in allen Richtungen aktiv zu werden wo
ist ein Entgegenkommen
liebte
auf die Grundlage ausgewogener
Interessen miteinander zu arbeiten und
die Länder die ihren Unternehmen
verboten haben sich in Russland zu
engagieren haben das unter einem enormen
Druck gemacht wir sagen jetzt ja wir
müssen leiden aber wir müssen Russland
zeigen wo der Hammer hängt und auch die
Vertreterinnen mit einem französischen
Namen
du ein Sicherheitsrat von den USA hat
wohl gesagt ich habe es heute gelesen
die USA wollen und nicht zulassen dass
die Erdölpreise zu schnell wachsen weil
und das wäre
für Russland ein gewinnen wenn nicht
weil der Sprit teuer sein wird in den
Tankstellen und der amerikanische Wähler
dann tiefer in die Tasche greifen muss
was soll niemand gerne macht und dann
auf die Regierung böse sein wird nein es
geht um Russland die denken nur an eins
Russland maximal zu bestrafen und das
hat natürliche Effekte für die
Wirtschaft für den sozialen Bereich aber
ich versichere Ihnen wir werden diese
Probleme in den Griff bekommen die uns
der Westen bereitet aus dem Wunsch
heraus nicht die eigene Sicherheit zu
gewährleisten es geht überhaupt nicht um
die Sicherheit des Westens sondern aus
dem Wunsch heraus die Ukraine als
Vorwand als Instrument zu nutzen
keine eigenständige Politik führen kann
weil es gibt nicht mehr viele Länder auf
der Welt die sich an das erlauben können
und wenn Sie wollen
und die Sanktionen sind deine
unabhängigkeitssteuer wenn Sie so wollen
und ihre zweite Frage die
Sicherheitsgarantien dann betrifft
[Musik]
Professoren
hat das vor siebeneinhalb Jahren zu
Papier gebracht im September 2014 nach
den Ereignissen auf der Krim und im
ukrainischen Osten hat folgendes
geschrieben
nur führt die Ukraine auf den Weg
falsche Hoffnung am Ende steht der
Untergang wie ich bin dafür der Ukraine
eine neutralen Status zu geben die
Wirtschaft auf die Beine zu stellen zu
und aus dem Feuer zu nehmen aus dem
Feuer der NATO und der Ukraine die beste
Variante für die Ukraine aber nein wir
Stacheln die Ukraine an damit sie
gegenüber
dann bockig ist und machen ja klar dass
du sie mal zum besten hören wird und wir
werden Putin besiegen und die zweite
Klasse auf unserer Seite und die Ukraine
spielen damit und sie wollen keine
Kompromisse mehr mit den Russen
heimgehen nein sie wollen harte
Positionen beziehen
und das wird ein böses Ende nehmen und
wir befassen uns jetzt damit ne dass wir
diesen Ausgang
provozierend und das wäre viel
sinnvoller eine neutrale nur Ukraine
keine zu schaffen und die USA müssen
diese Krise so schnell wie es geht
beenden das ist ja auch im russischen
Interesse aber an erster Stelle im
Interesse der Ukraine das wurde vor
siebeneinhalb Jahren geschrieben und
zwar in der Zeitschriften fahren Affairs
eine namhafte
Publikationen wo man nur sowohl auch
im Weißen Haus im State Department
darauf hört aber diesmal das nicht
stimmen soweit die Stimmung aber
und das wird nicht berücksichtigt weil
das Ziel war ein anderes es ging nicht
um die Sicherheit der Ukraine auf der
Grundlage des
interessenausgleiches zwischen Ukraine
USA Russland nein es ging darum die
Russische Föderation zu dämonisieren und
fertig zu machen und das war das Ziel
dass es zweifelsfrei zu meinem großen
bedauernden danke
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit herzlichen
Dank liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
verstehe Ihre Emotion aber
im Journalismus Journalismus sollte man
immer alle Fakten auf den Tisch springt
darum besuchen Sie unsere Webseite
meine Damen und Herren die Position des
russischen Außenminister Sergej lavrov
wahrscheinlich auch ein wenig ein Stück
Zeitgeschichte dieses hier zu erleben
ausdrücklich die russische Position und
sie bedarf absolut der Einordnung ich
freue mich sehr dass uns dies durch
diesen Vormittag begleitet der
Politikwissenschaftler Professor Thomas
Jäger von der Universität Köln
zugeschaltet aus Köln Professor
jägermann weiß gar nicht wo man anfangen
soll wir könnten wahrscheinlich eine
Stunde über das Gesagte über
Behauptungen und in den raumstellungen
hier sprechen aber beginnen wir mal bei
der Person labroff er ist der
Kommunikator des Präsidenten an dieser
Stelle
ja Außenminister labroff kommuniziert
die russische Position und man kann am
Ende dieses Gespräch mit Journalistinnen
und Journalisten aus mehreren Staaten
sagen das einzige was faktisch gestimmt
hat ist das Zitat von John mörschheimer
okay das ist relativ wenig Professor
Jäger dann müssen wir einfach jetzt noch
ein wenig stärker noch mal verschiedene
Behauptungen und Bemerkungen am
aufnehmen da war die Rede von
Präzisionswaffen und von Streumunition
es gibt ja tatsächlich die Einschätzung
von Experten dass die russische Armee in
den Angriffen auf die ukrainischen
Großstädte streumondition verwendet der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof ist
bereits kontaktiert worden mit
glücklicherweise Anfang kommender Woche
in einer Anhörung sich beide Positionen
anhören wie glaubwürdig wie stringent
sind diese Ausführung von Herrn labroff
bezogen auf diese Waffengattungen
na er hat das ja eingebettet in einer
Erzählung dir seit Jahren verträgt und
die lautet dass ich die NATO ausgeweitet
habe schon Begriff der nicht stimmt und
Russland bedroht habe sozusagen alles
russische soll vernichtet werden und in
diese Geschichte
bettet sich dann eben auch ein die
Vorstellung dass sich Russland in der
Ukraine verteidigt und
nun kann man das auf gar keinen Fall so
interpretieren wenn man die Gesamtlage
betrachtet aber die russische Führung
muss gegenüber ihrer Bevölkerung bei
dieser Geschichte bleiben denn das ist
genau der Grund mit dem sie
vorgeblich hier hier eingreifen musste
und dazu gehört dass man die russischen
Angriffe auf Verwaltungsgebäude und
andere Gebäude die eben mit schweren
Waffen erfolgen umdeutet als habe hier
die ukrainische Regierung zugeschlagen
und würde die ukrainische Führung das
eigene Volk
beschießen so wie es der Gazprom
gehörende Medienkanal gestern
ausführlich berichtet hat und dass dabei
eben auch Munition eingesetzt wird die
man in zivilgebiet schon mal überhaupt
nicht einsetzt
so wie man Ziele zivile Gebete überhaupt
nicht beschießt das wird eben zum
Vorwurf des Kriegsverbrechens das jetzt
den Straftatbestand der Aggression noch
komplettiert und der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof hat die Vermittlung
aufgenommen und wird das alles
untersuchen es ist alles dokumentiert
und all das was Labor 4 gesagt hat ist
sozusagen ein noch nicht mal ein
Kartenhaus ist es ein lufthaus es sind
Behauptungen die überhaupt keinen Grund
haben
und dieser Strafgerichtshof muss man
noch ergänzen wird von Russland aber
durchaus auch von anderen namenhaften
Staaten nicht anerkannt in seinen
Entscheidung aber reden wir über die
Wahrheit in Zeiten des Krieges Professor
Jäger da ist ja durchaus auch einiges
drin wo man sagen wir mal sehr sensibel
drauf schauen sollte Anfang dieser Woche
hat der russische Präsident Putin die
eine gewisse Alarmbereitschaft für die
Atomwaffen ausgelöst Russland ist die
stärkste Atom macht es gibt ein
mehrstufiges System
Herr labroff hat das jetzt hier noch mal
so dargestellt dass ein dritter
Weltkrieg quasi herbeigeredet würde
durch die Nato und ein dritter Weltkrieg
könne ja nur ein nuklearer Krieg sein so
ähnlich hatte er es formuliert
das klingt einfach dass man über eine
fast unsagbare Sache eine ganz lapidare
Einschätzung trifft ist das jetzt
sozusagen schon das entrückt sein von re
die Frage muss man sich generell Stellen
glaubt lavroff diese Propaganda die er
hier vertreibt er müsste besser
informiert sein aber es ist ein schönes
Beispiel dass Sie gewählt haben die
gesamte Debatte über Nuklearwaffen ist
ausgelöst worden von der Entscheidung
des russischen Präsidenten die
Alarmbereitschaft zu erhöhen und das
dann aus dem Besten von Journalisten
nachgefragt wird was bedeutet das denn
und lavrov das dann umdeutet ja was
reden sie denn als vom Nuklearkrieg was
soll man dazu sagen das ist sozusagen
eine russische Propaganda Methode der
wir in ganz vielen Fällen Aufsetzen von
der angeblichen Zusage die NATO nicht
nach Osten zu erweitern von der
Vorstellung dass die Ukraine
Nuklearwaffen entwickelt das die diese
Geschichte hat er heute mal weggelassen
er wollte wohl eine Pointe noch für den
nächsten Tag aufheben bis hin zu der
Tatsache dass die NATO und Nuklearwaffen
in den neuen NATO-Staaten wie sie in der
NATO Russland sagte heißen stationieren
will
außer wie gesagt außer dem Zitat von
John mörschheimer der sich damit sicher
nicht geadelt wird und der kein
Politiker ist der ganz spezifische
politikwissenschaftlich theoretische
Richtung vertritt war nichts ernst
vielleicht noch ein letzter Punkt aus
diesem internationalen Presse Briefing
also wir haben ja Kollegen gesehen von
ABC von NBC von France
aus London war glaube ich eine Kollegin
der BBC zugeschaltet also picking war
zugeschaltet lassen Sie uns noch einen
Punkt rausnehmen der durchaus
interessant war wenn es um andere
westliche Führer gehen dann war ein Name
jetzt genannt worden der von Herrn
labroff dann fast noch ein bisschen
geadelt wurde wenn man überhaupt in dem
Zusammenhang so sprechen kann das war
der französische Präsident macron der in
der Tat als
eu-ratsvorsitzender also Franzosen haben
ja die Rat Landschaft aufgefallen ist
dass er den Gesprächsfaden besonders eng
geflochten hat von einem Telefonat
gerade zur Stunde zwischen Putin und
macron war die Rede und von einer
möglichen Vermittlung in diesen Fragen
ist das ein ernsthafter Ansatz oder ist
das auch wieder nur so ein bisschen
nebelwischerei
nun nachdem Außenminister davor vorher
den französischen Finanzminister mit dem
Hahn den Symbol Frankreichs verglichen
hat wollte hier vielleicht wieder was
gut machen und seinem französischen im
französischen Präsidenten ein wenig
Honig um den Hund schmieren nein genauso
wie Bundeskanzler Scholz realisiert hat
dass er vom Präsident Putin an der Nase
herumgeführt wurde dass er mit ihm
gespielt wurde hat er französische
Präsident das inzwischen realisiert er
steht in der anderen Situation weil er
einen Wahlkampf direkt vor sich hat und
er wollte das eigentlich nutzen um aus
innenpolitischen Gründen um als
derjenige dazustehen der diese Lage
entschärft
und er behält jetzt die Kommunikation
aufrecht aber Frankreich spielt hier die
dritte vierte fünfte Geige in diesem
Spiel das
normandie-format war die ganze Zeit von
Russland nicht ernst genommen und man
hat auch in dieser in diesem
Pressegespräch feststellen können die
einzigen die ernst genommen werden von
Russland sind die USA denn in der Sicht
Russlands ist Europa eine Kolonie der
USA und die Ukraine eine Kolonie soll
eine Kolonie der USA werden und ich
meine das ist
hanebüchen nach Unsinn